how many refugees has Poland taken zero
and you're proud of that if you are
asking me if you if you are asking me
about Muslim uh Muslims illegal
immigration none not even one will come
to Poland not even one if it's illegal
we we took over 2 million ukrainians who
are working who are peaceful in Poland
we will not receive even one Muslim
because this is what we promised but I
asked not about illegal immigrants I
asked about refugees and Jean CL junker
the commission President says that
you're racist you sound proud of the
fact that you haven't taken any refugees
but this is why Poland is so safe this
is the the the reason why we had not
even uh one terrorist attack look at the
streets in Poland and we can be called
populists nationalists racists I don't
care can make all the jokes you want
about Poland and Polish people but God
they got it right right